das ist schon so 5 cm oder nee mehr das
ist schon mehr aber die sind cool aus
danke schön genauso wie du auch wir
passen farbig finde ich voll ich finde
das voll cool dass du rot bist und ich
schwarz und du hast ein Herz ne ja
passend eigentlich was hier Luft stehen
ach wir sind einfach hier kann er
vielleicht sein dass du beiden oder
jetzt schon sagen will ist dass der kann
sein ja
hallo Leute ähm hier ist malwanne und
Mathea hello ich kriege einfach nur noch
die mega Stars hier vor die Kamera ich
fühle mich wirklich sind so wie Steven
gädchen oder so der wirklich jetzt so
dieses nächste Level erreicht hat du
kannst Deutsch sprechen oder ja ich kann
da ein bisschen Deutsch sprechen ich
bekomme gerade rein als nächstes haben
wir die Künstlerin Mathea
hey hallo
Leute tolles Outfit ähm danke schön
trägst du da heute äh gute Frage
ist aus meinem kleiderkasse habe ich
schon super lange ich weiß nicht mehr
neuen Song rausgebracht ja genau warum
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge
32 Cocktails das muss sagen die
Grinch heute machen wir Cocktails zum
Thema Herz yes wow ja ja aber du hast
ein bisschen das ist ein bisschen unfair
bei dir weil du hast so lange Nägel habe
aber früher gemacht
nee eigentlich nicht äh das ist uns
besoffen zu machen eigentlich nur so
und jetzt gehen wir einkaufen
okay bis gleich tschüss
wir waren Einkaufen also meine Knie
Zutaten okay ja sie wahrscheinlich schon
so einen Blick erschafft sind auf jeden
Fall Erdbeeren ich habe die dann äh
Minze
ich ziehe mir mal ganz langsam hier
rüber
das wird hier ganz spannend heute ja ich
habe ja noch nie ein Cocktail gemixt
selber noch nie noch nie dann habe ich
hier ich weiß nicht genau
welche Geschmacksrichtung hat dieser
likörche drauf oh
ja
100 Punkte
dann habe ich hier Salz ganz wichtig
Chiliflocken und dann hier steht drauf
Zahnstocher aber es ist nicht als
Zahnstocher gedacht und sprudeln
warum hast du dich für Gerolsteiner
entschieden ich weiß nicht kenne mich
beim deutschen Pass auch noch gar nicht
so aus
die Internet
sorry
wir haben ganz andere Produkte in
Österreich wir machen einen kleinen Test
Test
findest es bestimmt ekelhaft und wärst
du so eingegangen tschüss
ja es hat ein Sprudelwasser ist
irgendwie schlimmer in Erinnerung gehabt
ich finde wasser kann man nicht so viel
falsch machen wie war echt immer also
bei Wasser ohne sprudeln meistens so ein
bisschen nach Pudding also die sind so
fest im Mund nicht so flüssig weißt du
was ich meine also ich bin auch zum
Beispiel Vanillepudding also
Berliner Wasser ist so ein bisschen so
ja
es ist tatsächlich besser als gedacht so
jetzt zeig mir doch mal deine okay
Zutaten ich bin sehr gespannt alles klar
ich habe das Gefühl wir gehen schon mal
so eine gleich also eine ähnliche
Richtung okay ich habe frische Chili
Limette eine Wassermelone eine sehr
kleine Wassermelone Melone
Melone hä ach so Mango ja ich bin ein
bisschen traurig dass ich noch nicht sah
ich würde immer gerne schon sagen warum
aber ich sag's später
genau und dann noch Rotkäppchen und um
uns was Schlechtes zu tun Prosecco aber
eine Zutaten habe ich auch noch
vergessen die habe ich schon zu Hause
deswegen dachte ich komme
tschüß
ich bin sehr gespannt besonders hier auf
den freue ich mich auf jeden Fall ja
schmeckt nach Eisen
finde ich ja ganz krass sogar als ob man
an so einem Stange so und jetzt würde
ich sagen mögen die durch Spiele
und das musst du jetzt auf
österreichisch sagen weil Alvaro das
letztens auf Spanisch gesagt
ich muss mal kurz überlegen wie ich
jetzt anfangen weil er ist ja mein
erstes Mal
mit mir was
eigentlich ähm einmal zur WM von Stefan
Raab oha
und ich war halt auch nur so einen Tag
also nein ich war noch nie in Österreich
ich wollte schon immer mal nach Wien
weil Wien so schön das stimmt hatten wir
nicht damals bei als wir uns
kennengelernt haben über Wien gesprochen
irgendwas
ja wann kommst du denn jetzt haben wir
es auf Video weißt du jetzt kannst du
das nicht mehr aus ja du ich bin ja zum
Sommer öfters mal da und im Sommer ist
wieder am schönsten
[Musik]
kleine Cocktail Queen dann mach mal dein
Problem mache ich mache das mal aber
wehe deiner wird besser als meiner
glücklich ich habe mich letztens
irgendwie so ein Spiel spielen was war
das
und dann habe ich ähm
habe ich gewonnen
Anfänger glücklich auf deine erste
Single voll der Hit stimmt Anfänger
Glück
zur Vorbereitung dass du kommst Spotify
also Instagram das heißt eigentlich
kenne ich alles sonst
so absolut guck ich so und so
den kenne ich gar nicht
doch
ich habe den so tot gefeiert wirklich
gedacht scheiße
sag bloß du brauchst ein Herz Ausstecher
kannst du diesen Song rausbringen der
Stern heißt
ähm oder vielleicht sage ich mal dazu
es ist professionell das was ich hier
mache
oh
ja das sieht doch ganz gut
aussucht habe
ja Kochen ja ich koche tatsächlich
eigentlich ganz gerne
das ist ja eigentlich quasi dein Bruder
manchmal ist es ja das was man als Beruf
macht macht man ja dann privat nicht so
wer das stimmt so unter der Dusche
manchmal tatsächlich ja
ich glaube der ist gut finden würde wenn
sie anfängt
weißt du aus welchem Video ich dich also
ich das das erste Mal so dich gesehen
habe ihr erzählt bitte ich das äh sieben
Schichten
Mayonnaise Salat Video oh mein Gott
das ist ja 100 Jahre her ne ja das kann
schon sein dann weißt du was ich auch
noch in Erinnerung habe dieses da warst
du doch in so einem Innenhof
Heidi das Brot und Käse gemacht also
dann würdest Du schon sagen dein Traum
ist in Erfüllung gegangen du bist bei
einem malwanne Video dabei ja es hat
sechs Jahre gedauert und sechs Jahre
gedauert bisschen zu lange für meinen
Geschmack
so ein Herz für mich ist sie gut ich
weiß es nicht
geht okay ziemlich schlecht
ja
nächstes Jahr erst wieder ich war
letztes Jahr zum ersten Mal auf Tour
wollte ich gerade sagen weil du bist
meine erste Tour war genau im ersten
Doktor also wäre genau am ersten
Lockdown gewesen
ja deswegen hat das jetzt bisschen
gedauert aber jetzt im September was
soweit und es war sehr toll und ich
freue mich schon sehr auf nächstes Mal
und ich kann verraten es wird auf jeden
Fall nächstes Jahr soweit sein
möchtest du hier eine Erdbeere kosten ja
sehr gerne die sieht nämlich sehr gut
aus ja wie war das jetzt noch mal ich
habe mich so ein bisschen versucht zu
informieren von einem sollte ich so
einzeln nehmen von einem 15 es kann aber
jetzt es sind 50 50 Chance ich muss
sagen beide haben extrem viel Alkohol
aber deswegen habe ich doch das äh
Sprudel Gerolsteiner Sprudelwasser hier
dabei
ja und wie kommst du so auf deine Songs
also es ist alles nur dein so ja so
wirklich im Leben erlebt hast oder
schreibst du auch mal so nee tatsächlich
schreibe ich alles sehr aus meinem Leben
gegriffen ich kann gar nicht anders ich
hatte mal so eine Phase wo ich dachte
boah mir geht das gerade alles ein
bisschen zu nah also das ist mir alles
bisschen zu öffentlich gerade besonders
nach meinem ersten Song so oder der war
ja sehr persönlich und ich habe da hat
dann auch ganz viele so Interviews zu
fragen dazu bekommen und irgendwie war
mir das ein bisschen zu wild und zu
privat und dann hatte ich so eine Phase
wo ich mir dachte boah ich muss jetzt
irgendwie irgendwas bei den Haaren
herbeizehen aber es hat gar nicht
geklappt da wurde auch nie dann ein Song
Release deswegen hat das jetzt auch so
lange gedauert mein erstes Album kam ja
2020 und wir haben jetzt 2.000
excuse me wir haben 2023 ja und es
kommen erst wieder neue Songs benutzt
auch tatsächlich so Musik einfach dafür
Sachen zu verarbeiten und mir selber
Sachen einfach leichter zu machen wenn
das mal auf dem Text oder auf dem Song
geschrieben ist auf dem Beat geschrieben
ist dann fühlt sich direkt leichter an
einfach so rein nehme
ich scharf
ein Hoch bist du so eine scharfe Maus
also magst Du scharfe Sachen ja
eigentlich schon aber das ist ein Schaf
Klasse so ich mache das hier immer so
halb professionell ich weiß nicht ob man
Teller für mich ich muss da was mixen
nämlich noch
das ist so profimäßig aus was du da gut
aus ne sieht so gut aus ich muss hier
mal gucken
wow ah ja
das geht in dieselbe Richtung nie macht
das jemand bei diesem Format heute habe
ich mir gedacht das ist mal super cute
ist dass so ein Zeug rein zu trinken das
ist ja sweet und dann mache ich das auch
schön sieht das denn bei dir auch gerade
gesehen weil die sieht auch cool aus mir
ist ein bisschen die Konstruktion
ist einfach so professionell aus okay
ich glaube es ist soweit zum ersten Mal
ich bin so stolz auf Dich great Moves
auch hier reingemacht war das richtig
oder war das falsch das ist nicht
schlimm also du kannst hier und dann
kommt das nicht mehr
Rauschen Farbe der hat eine wunderschöne
Farbe sieht total cool aus
[Applaus]
wow
was geht eigentlich ich finde das geht
voll
aber deiner sieht auch perfekt aus
deswegen ja ich habe heute gar keine
Ahnung wie das schmeckt ja ich habe noch
nicht einmal zwischen gekostet und ich
weiß auch nicht wie ich das mit der Deko
hier löse oder ob ich hier noch nur eins
und Ding drauf lassen so wir sind jetzt
fertig boah Entschuldigung wir sind
jetzt fertig tolle zwei Cocktails oder
ich verstehe nicht warum wir so ähnliche
Cocktails machen weil das ist ja nicht
nur als erstes wenn uns beide für Frucht
entschieden gut das ist auch ja beide
für so ein Rand entschieden ob das schon
krass beide dachten Obst Herzen aber
aber deiner sieht so nach einem Medium
glücklichen Herz irgendwie aus nur ja
einer meiner schon sehr mein Herz ist
frisch verliebt deine ist so für die
Kinder bleiben zusammen
möchtest du an
fangen
das hier ist der ich überlege gerade
noch ganz kurz gesagt strawberry Herz
aber wie cool
Herz einfach wieder ein Song danke schön
wow
das ist der herzcocktail so einfach wäre
es gewesen das ist der herz-cocktail
passend zu meiner neuen Single Herz und
der ist verfeinert mit einer Note
Limette dass die die Zutat habe ich ja
vorher schon vorgestellt dass die
Erdbeere ja um so ein bisschen spicy das
noch zu machen auch passend zu meinem
Song weil es geht ja auch so ein
bisschen darum dass ich jetzt nicht ganz
happy bin dass ich mich so so verliebt
habe so schnell so unerwartet nicht
geplant es ist ein bisschen spicy
deswegen die Flocken
[Gelächter]
könnte süßer sein süßer ja sieht so süß
aus aber nicht so süß
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
bisschen
Zucker oder sowas
ganz toll
aus wie Erdbeere es schmeckt aber noch
die Kieler und Limette
weißt du was wir machen müssen weil ich
glaube wir müssen uns die Dekoration auf
die Zunge legen so jeder so ein Herz und
dann ein Stück nehmen und dann kauen und
dann ist es vielleicht das ist doch ein
guter Plan
das macht
aber noch mehr Herzen halt ne ich würde
mal sagen wir machen einfach mal kurz
weiter
okay also meiner heißt Herz
vielseitiges Herz so heißt einer wow ein
Herz ist ja vielseitig also man kann ja
sehr viel mit dem Herzen fühlen am
liebsten fühlt man natürlich die süßen
Momente die machen am meisten Spaß aber
natürlich ist man dann auch mal sauer
oder bitter oder scharf wenn man so ein
bisschen aufgeregt ist und das habe ich
erstmal mit dem Tahin Pulver das ist da
halt alles drin dann habe ich aber sauer
Limette süß Mango und Wassermelone
okay okay ja ich koste es auch mal
wollen wir mal ein Strohhalm also ich
finde es geil aber es schmeckt
tatsächlich bisschen nach Gurke
Wassermelone schmeckt einfach nach gut
aber ich finde den Rand eigentlich ganz
geil hier ja
gar nicht so süß sondern es ist eher wie
so ein Marinade
ähm hast du schon mal Mango mit Tahin
oder was
schmeckt so geil erstmal die
Wassermelone gar nicht schlecht oder
und jetzt nehmen wir die Mango
aber ich bin auch nicht so der krasse
Mango Film achso okay also ich finde den
Drink an sich ganz gut als erinnert mich
aber auch noch irgendwas anderes daran
Tomatensaft mit Schuss einfach so ein
Stück
kommen ja gleich ja
gefallen sehr schön guck mal dein Handy
jetzt raus und dann spielst du mal mir
den Song das mache ich das aufgeregt
wenn Leute
[Gelächter]
das ist so ein richtiger Song wo ich so
jetzt wo ich wieder Auto fahre Fenster
aufmachen möchte und so richtig mein
Leben führen können
vielen Dank
durfte
Stream Herz überall wo ihr sehen könnt
unten findet ihr alles von Mathea und
wir sehen uns dann auf dein Konzert ne
ja in Wien
ja ja ja ja Tschüss